so a recent article from Yahoo Finance
revealed to us that YouTube consumption
and viewership is up 64% and so in this
video I'm gonna be talking about two big
reasons about why now is time to go
all-in with YouTube in terms of pivoting
your plan pivoting your business and
even strategies for making money from
home I'm gonna be diving into some case
studies but if you're new to this show
this is coffee with Cannell episode zero
zero for today I think it's the first
episode I'm actually drinking coffee so
let me know in the comments what are you
sipping on and this is a show where I
bring you on to talk about business
social media online video as well as
pivoting your plan so that you are not
profiting from this pandemic but
profiting during this pandemic in the
midst of every obstacle I really believe
there's hidden opportunity and of course
we're trying to make the most of
everything that's happening to provide
for our families for our future so hey
it's good to see if you're here live
Kyle Jeffery Christopher Nolan hit the
like button and let's dive right into
this I want to give you really quick
before we dump jump into the having
guests on and I'm gonna drop the link
for you if you want to get in the
waiting area but right now it's time to
go all-in with YouTube and here's why
Yahoo Finance did a reveal to us that
social media users are seven times more
likely wealth to consume alcohol right
now so there's always the negative side
of what's happening with coronavirus but
they did some surveys and some people
said that for social media consumption
it's about alcohol consumption social
media consumption 64% say that their
YouTube viewership has increased
powerful right and I want to actually
show you because you know when we are
here on Facebook and on think marketing
this is kind of the behind-the-scenes
the nitty gritty the marketing strategy
kind of stuff and here's what we've been
seeing happening at think media over the
last
you really sense this lockdown we've
been seeing a massive increase in
viewership a massive increase in views
per day
we've been doubling down I want to
remind you creators create right now
it's time to go all-in with YouTube and
I hope you're creating content I hope
you're creating more than you're
consuming and this is the time to of
course be leaning in but check out these
YouTube analytics from behind the scenes
at think media and what we can see here
if we look over the last 90 days is that
the YouTube viewership right when the
lockdown started on March 16th we were
getting 62,000 views a day over unthink
media and that has gone up now to around
50,000 views a day over double right and
so and that's been consistent two things
one it has been the fact that we are
going about five six videos uploads a
week so we doubled our uploads and our
shows and our live streams but the
biggest traffic generators have actually
been our old video library videos that
are ranked in search that are becoming
popular right now as people are
searching for certain topics so my
friends you need to go all-in on YouTube
you might say well my views haven't gone
up well I think it's important to think
about what niche are you in how are you
positioned are you doing something that
is relevant to right now in terms of
your positioning your actual video ideas
your topics you know just like
restaurants have been disrupted and you
can't go sit in a restaurant depending
on where you are in the world as of
during this lockdown
online shopping and uber eats and post
mates is going up so you got a pivot you
got to pivot your plan you got a pivot
not panic and so the number one reason
to go all-in on YouTube right now is
because growth is up people are locked
down social media consumptions up but
most people are consuming I need you
creating okay but the second reason to
go all-in on YouTube right now is
ecommerce ecommerce another article I
read said that ecommerce orders have
gone up 50%
now this shouldn't surprise us like
we're stopping from home we can't we
either can't go to the store or we don't
want to go to the store or we're scared
and so we're shopping from home and so
people are ordering more things online
with a powerful thing is you can connect
YouTube to e-commerce even if you don't
have your own product that you're
selling online you can do it through
affiliate marketing and so the same kind
of thing has been happening we just
heard and know that Amazon Radice
reduced their affiliate Commission's but
this month our personal affiliate
Commission's have been going crazy over
on Amazon we've done something like
almost a million dollars in revenue in
Amazon sales and then of course our cut
of that so far there's a couple more
days in the month it's thirty five
thousand eight hundred and three dollars
right
that's some serious order increase
impact increase and that's happening in
e-commerce
now I'm empathetic I know some people
are really hurting right now and by the
way if you want to make an impact that's
why we are able to continue to support
twenty five kids through compassion
international that's why we are able to
do whatever and I'm not here to justify
doing well in business I'm here to help
you to say look you can pivot your plan
you can maximize people are so shopping
online people still gotta order stuff
people still you get the 24 hour cookie
and if people order toilet paper paper
or cleaning supplies even if you talk
about cameras you're gonna get a
percentage of that sale on Amazon and so
now it's the time friends to go all-in
on YouTube all-in on e-commerce and of
course that's what this show is all
about to help you with those types of
strategies and if you haven't watched
our free masterclass make sure you watch
it I think masterclass calm I explain
how to do both the best strategies
working to grow on YouTube right now and
get discovered even if you're starting
from scratch and how to connect it to
e-commerce even if you don't have a
product so you can kind of model what
we're doing no matter what your industry
or niches provided you pick something
that's actually relevant to what people
are doing and needing right now there's
a link to that you could go to think
master class calm or depending on where
you want
you're watching this the links either in
the comments or down below and so though
right now it's time to go all in this
show is coffee with candles so now I
want to be able to answer your questions
I dropped a link for you to jump on and
join me but go ahead and click that link
if you want to come on the show remember
you got to have the ability to I drop a
link on YouTube as well you got to have
the ability to be have like a webcam a
good internet connection and some decent
audio please and we'll bring bring you
on to talk about any kind of questions
you have and so um hit me up and let me
know are you going all-in with YouTube
right now and are you what is your niche
what is your channel hit me up in the
comments wherever you're watching this
and how have you been doing and pivoting
your plan during this time hit me up and
let me know but we've got Chris coming
on here in just a second smash like if
you're getting value so far maybe tag
somebody that needs to think different
that needs to maybe pivot their plan
business owners entrepreneurs and
content creators but Chris how's it
going in on with you just so you know
I'm a new VR a member joined in the
recent late week and a half so I'm
really focusing on getting clear right
now on my niche and I'm also pivoting so
I wanted to talk to you about kind of
what I'm doing and get your opinion on
this so I am a law student very
interested in becoming a social media
lawyer in the future and so I've been
for the past two years been doing law
school content vlogs information about
being in law school stuff like that with
the quarantine I saw an opportunity for
me to start doing social media law
videos I dropped my first one which is
all on Coppa i have a few scripts about
the laws regarding social media and how
content creators need to be aware of
them but i still want to do my law
school content because that's where my
audience
what's the channel it's just my name
youtube.com slash Chris V so I call
myself the legal creator that's and I'm
dropping my first podcast episode this
week that I did with a Ian Corzine who
is big YouTube's got a great channel and
does a lot of this stuff so I dropped my
first video on Coppa so my thing is this
am I starting to separate into two
niches doing social media law and doing
law school advice and tips and stuff
like that or am i combining two niches
together do you think it would there's a
possibility that this is a combo that
I'm doing and I'm not separating those
two audiences because that's what I'm
afraid of is am I trying to go after too
much by doing this great yeah I think
that the principle is I think you're
doing it exactly right and for those
watching don't over optimize too soon so
of course niche down well you're already
niche down like you're not talking about
tai chi or cryptocurrency so the the
niche is clear in terms of the legal
legal creator i think the thing with
over optimizing is people sometimes
hyper niche and so i see here's the
opportunity i do see the difference i do
see that it could maybe go one way or
the other
but at this early stage of your first
few videos at this early stage of just
getting out a ton of content i think you
want to be jumping on i would jump on
any legal trend that's relevant like i
would jump on stuff in the media which
we call influence surfing and trend
surfing and in hyper-growth
that other program that comes with VRA
there's two trainings that go deep on
those so anything regarding and the
people you are interviewing ian coming
on I would look at what they're doing I
would do almost anything in the
playground of your niche and then
success leaves clues which videos are
winning which videos are getting results
which videos are showing a trend which
videos are leading to the most
what are they saying in the comments
what videos are they asking for next in
terms of optimization of your brand and
even narrowing down you always want to
stay true to yourself in your passion
and people who wrestle with this what do
I just listen to what might my audience
is saying or do I follow my passion well
you have to do both in my opinion you
already kind of know which way you want
to go but then you also let your
audience steer it and you might really
lean into the social media side or maybe
really helping students becomes the
thing that that blows up I would say do
both though and and and even do other
things and maybe not feel so limited and
don't overthink it drop videos because
the thesis of VRA 2 is your one ranked
video away from changing your life in
business so that you might go into by
the way a quote-unquote third direction
but awesome
then that's the direction that maybe
gives you more clarity and you really
double down and go that way does that
make sense
my intention when I went into law school
I was creating YouTube videos but not
consistently I was doing a different
niche and then I saw a need for law
school students to have information so I
started doing that but then I saw the
need for social media content creators
to have lawyers who or people who
understand the law explain these things
on YouTube and that's why Ian blew up
and there's a couple of other lawyers so
that's kind of the generation of it and
I recently pivoted my plan where I'm
still gonna do one social do one law
school video per month but my plan is
with releasing a video each week to do
one sort of law school video to social
media videos and a podcast so if if
that's clear enough I mean and me that
was kind of mine from what you just
explained it seems to me like that's a
clear plan and that's a clear path and
because the social media law stuff will
rank better than the law school stuff
there's a bigger market for it it's also
what I love to talk about but I'm still
helping students who have come to me and
said your videos made me go to law
school and that's what so I just want to
say like I got that from you I had the
opportunity at law school I was sitting
there and somebody came up it was like
videos made me go to law school and I
was like oh my goodness that's
incredible but then I thought you know
what no watching Sean's videos is what
made me do create on YouTube so it's
just the trickle-down so I want to thank
you for letting me come on getting me on
that clear path I am in YouTube's hyper
growth right now and anybody watching if
you're not in VR a it's incredible
cuz just the the value I got out of the
first few videos to get clear may has
blown up everything that I'm doing it
and has really set up my plan so thank
you I appreciate it Sean well thank you
Chris I appreciate your kind words super
grateful you're a part of our VR a
community we got some really cool stuff
coming up so stay locked into that
Facebook group and Congrats on what you
already got going I think it's it's cool
to see and I love that you're taking
action and I'm glad that we were able to
hang out on coffee with Channel today I
appreciate you Cheers
all right well hey super great first
session there don't offer over optimize
at the start here's one of the things I
see a lot of us get stuck in is
overthinking I think you need to think
things through then follow through you
got to start with the end in mind every
battle is won before it's even fought
you gotta have a strategy you got a
reverse engineer but we probably push
that point so hard I think media that it
can lead us into over optimization and
where we're gonna get a lot of data and
feedback is taking massive action so I
hope that wherever you're watching from
and hit like if you're getting value so
far we're having other people jump on
for the Q&A show today but take massive
action get like a halfway decent plan
and then put it to work and then
evaluate and double down on what's
working and I'm pumped because we have
Frank coming up Frank how's it going man
good doing really good were you watching
from what's happening to you on the
ground during this pandemic
and what's your business okay so I'm
watching from Dallas Texas and um Copic
it's actually I mean obviously it's
affecting everyone but I work for a my
full-time job is working for a software
like development company called
church-based that helps churches with
you know apps and websites so really
we've been a little bit more busy then I
guess you could say your average company
open you know churches to be able to
move forward in that area because they
all need it right now
exactly got it yeah exactly and then
kind of the reason that I'm on is
because I started to youtube channel
I've had another one for like three
years but it's more of just a personal
thing where I do like just the more
podcasts about like stories people's
stories getting their stories out there
but then I've been watching you for a
minute now actually found you through
Benny Perez's Church was just really
cool but um I've been watching you for a
minute and I really wanted to like have
a Anish and one of the biggest things
that I enjoy doing and that honestly I
started making money off of was creating
videos off of my phone and you know free
mobile editing apps and things like that
and so I wanted to kind of like create
videos showing people how to edit on a
mobile device and not need all of this
programming all of this like crazy
equipment and just film on your phone
edit on your phone but I'm kind of
running into like the end goal is
teaching people to just start and to
know that you got exactly what you need
to get started so I don't know if mobile
editing is the niche does that make
sense yeah really good and so a couple
things I mean I think that it is a
phenomenal niche and those things aren't
mutually exclusive obviously it's a
little bit related to think media here's
the power of what you're saying you want
to it's nice
you want to have a practical way to
reach people I think the most practical
way to win on you too
is to have a practical way to serve
people people have questions about
gardening they find you and then you can
inspire them about life people have
questions about a fitness program they
find you and then you could talk about
your faith people have questions about
mobile editing but then they could
realize that we really what they're
dealing with is that they need help with
confidence they need to help with
motivation and these other aspects so
the helping people start like if you
made a channel that was about helping
people start I don't think it would do
well if a lot of times people when they
start directly in a way of personal
development or mindset it's just kind of
hard to stand out where and and and yes
people search those topics but they
actually search way more for how to edit
with certain app on the new galaxy phone
so I I think that your niche is super
good I think yes there's people doing it
even you know we touch on that my friend
Dean Inman you know has a channel that's
kind of devoted to smartphone stuff but
what people also don't understand and I
don't know if you're saying this but
just to add value to the entire
community here sometimes we fear our
competition we're like others too much
competition there's already somebody
doing with doing it you don't even
realize how big mobile is mobile is
millions of people millions of searches
a month and it's the widest market way
more people have a smartphone than have
a camera or even can afford a camera
especially over time so especially
churches to limited resources limited
budgets so I think it's one of the
greatest ways to serve people if I give
you a little bit of advice obviously
this would be hard to do at the start
because it'd be expensive or you have to
find you know a way to do it I think
niching down even more than like how to
edit on your phone that's good a
specific app is a good thing to train on
but specific phones is a really good
thing to train on you know we mainly
touch on iPhones here at think media
simply because we have iPhones you know
what I mean and like any untruly I'm
like do I buy another phone do I do I
have to learn another phone but so many
people are like well what about Android
or what about this Windows Phone or what
about this particular galaxy phone and
so one of the best ways to get big on
YouTube is to start small you want to
start small to get big maybe one
specific phone specific apps specific
accessories
and it's impossible even for a media
company like pink media to cover all of
those distinctions it's impossible for
Nick Newman and Dena Minh and even other
people to even touch on all of those so
I want to encourage you and also
everybody the world is abundant that's
like even though there's a lot of people
talking about what you probably want to
do on YouTube I think this is an amazing
idea I think you're absolutely on the
right track let me know how that
resonates and if you have any follow-up
questions about that or clarity ya know
I love that that that cleared things up
a whole lot because mobile editing can
be massive but just simply niching down
to phone and apps I think is gonna make
a huge difference and honestly for me it
was a little overwhelming because coming
up with like ideas and not just ideas
because I loved doing it first of all so
I'll keep doing it regardless but
obviously the end goal is for financial
income to start coming in you know so
you can set your family up and help
people all that great stuff and so I was
like having a hard time how I'm gonna
optimize it and not more than more than
that like monetize it because as we all
know like YouTube ads isn't really the
best way to go and I was just kind of
like maybe eventually would be
sponsorships through a specific app
which would only happen if I did exactly
just that niche down to like specific
apps specific phones and things of that
nature 100% and you know I think a
couple things though is you know in the
past I've talked about how YouTube ads
are not necessarily the best or whatever
but I would challenge that obviously
this strategy takes time but um you know
one of our best performing videos is how
to make a video on your phone start to
finish and in the lifetime of that video
on YouTube ads that videos generated
four thousand one hundred and five
dollars that's pretty legit money off of
just the one upload by the way this one
upload is a combination of four other
uploads so we took a four part series
and combine it into one with Q&A in
between so we really stretched
that's definitely kind of a more
advanced thing to think about but and
then in it we talk about some
accessories and whatnot so then
affiliate marketing is layered on top of
there and and everything else so I say
all that to encourage you that actually
monetization in the niche you're talking
about
is abundant yes brand deals yes
affiliate marketing yes YouTube ads yes
I think apps there's this is crazy but
when you really start to think down the
road and you think you know maybe
someday you are so involved in apps that
you partner with an app company because
you have so much insight about what
creators need or maybe you even build
your own you know what I mean like we're
living in the pivot your plan area like
there's never been a better time to lean
into entrepreneurship and that's and I'm
just kind of painting that wide picture
of this can go a lot of places but let's
bring it down it's gonna start with I
believe getting at least one video out a
week adding value solving answering
specific questions solving specific
people's questions related to an app or
how to do one thing in one app or how to
fix the deal and get the best looking
camera settings on a certain windows
phone that's obscure but a couple
thousand people search for it a month
that's where it starts and so have you
already started when are you gonna start
posting your videos a week er yeah so I
try to do one a week at least one a week
just because obviously full time job and
family and all that good stuff
cool yeah so try to come hell or high
water get that one video out a week man
it's the commitment it's it's it's I
know it takes grit and by the way it's
awesome you got a family so I've been
hustling without kids but now I'm 18
weeks in my wife pregnant boy on the way
Sean Bradley candle and just got the
chromosome test back because we are 35
and 36 you know feeling that baby's
healthy so we're feeling super blessed
man we're so grateful and but anyways
I'll have to learn the whole new season
of juggling everything but you got to
commit because momentum comes from from
fifty-two videos a year man one a week
find a way and some weeks do to save one
up you know batch produce do whatever
you got to do definitely stick with that
that one a week and I appreciate you
Franklin super grateful you came on and
I love what you're doing to help
churches yes sir appreciate you happy
for you with your family and everything
god bless you brother thank you so much
god bless
yeah yeah yeah hey this is coffee with
Cannell episode zero zero I have no idea
and let me know what you're drinking and
I'm stepping onto coffee today for the
first time I've had some kombucha some
hotter but we're in a hardcore season at
think media working on some new stuff so
I'm sipping on the coffee hit like if
you're getting value and let me know
what you're watching from even on the
replay hit me up in the comments where
people are joining us we got casts
sipping on some San Pellegrino
thanks for the congratulations and a lot
of feedback on Frank's niche cuz a lot
of people are saying yes I need help
editing on Android yes I bounce between
my iPhone and older so D Sony camera and
so super great niche creators create and
the cool thing is all of us can get
started creating no excuses one video a
week with just our smartphone juliet's
got some coffee in LA we got Dallas in
the house we got rocky Monique Lisa so
good to see you guys we got green tea we
got we got Minneapolis or Maryland in
the house we got vanilla chai tea
delicious Denmark hey good to see
everybody man Prince purpos'd is up next
Prince purpose how can I help what are
you up to
where's where are you are streaming from
and Wow let me take this hold on one
second Los Angeles my man man well my
youtube channel is as is an artist page
but um I do uh I just I just launched a
digital marketing company so I've been
like maintaining my church's social
media as well as in-house media is kind
of a larger Church here in LA so there's
lots of people
it's it's called in his presence okay um
anyhow I've been able to maintain their
their marketing as it pertains to like
their social media and things like that
and I have my own and I've kind of
branched off into doing my own marketing
company but I'm still they're kind of
like my first clients now I've stepped
away from being involved there full-time
and I'm picking up other clients so I'm
just one thank you for letting me on man
I pick up so much man and I know you
have a history from being in the church
and kind of going out and branched and
doing your own thing so it's really
inspiring to me but uh yeah man I mean
tips specifically about you know where
to go to to help build brands you know I
know you have a lot of content on brands
and and how to build brands but I'm
dealing with clients now to help them
build their brands while I'm building my
own it's kind of like a dream come true
because everything that I do I'm able to
apply to myself my youtube channel
specifically is is niched as at the
music artists I do like motivational
Christian hip-hop type of you know music
and sounds and stuff like that Sprint's
part beside oh I know you can probably
look at it right now I did somewhat like
a campaign awhile back and I was able to
generate you know close to like 300
followers or something like that not
quite there but almost there but I've
kind of like pulled away from it but I'm
jumping back into it but as a yeah as a
music artist I'm not really sure like
one of those are like me ministering at
a school so I do speak to like youth and
different things like that and I don't
know it's kind of its kind of all over
the place but as an artist I'm not
really sure like we're not where to
start and some of these people that I'm
gonna help market and brand I know they
would want to look at what I'm doing and
how my success has been and I'd love to
be you know well over a thousand at
least you know I've been able to help my
church get to that level just because
there's so many people that are actually
there but my own personal brand I
haven't been able to accomplish that so
I guess my question more so than
anything is like how did like yeah I
guess hone in on a specific thing for
different different niches for example I
have two two clients right now already
my first week in business I have two
clients one of them
is a psychologist and he wants to brand
himself you know just entirely Brennan
himself like Oprah and releasing content
podcasts and all that sort of stuff
another one is a is an actor you know
the Axel and Broadway and does Lion King
and all sort stuff he wants to do kind
of like positive Christian spoken word
pieces and different things like that
and kind of just blow up his uh you know
his own personal brand and then I have
obviously myself and then the church at
this time so I know that was a lot but I
know you're really bright guy so I'm
sure you got some insight yeah cool so
just if I understand the question you're
kind of it is are you asking for maybe a
little bit of strategy and advice or
it's freelance side of things of running
your digital marketing company right now
and then maybe how that relates to also
your personal brand yes sir awesome so I
love what you're doing you know it's
very similar to my path again I was
full-time at a church and then I was
freelancing full time with three main
clients you know I got those clients to
two thousand two thousand one thousand
so I was making five thousand a month
and then I had my side hustle so I was
about sixty thousand a year of just the
freelance income monthly and and then I
had my side hustle of a couple hundred
dollars a month I'm you know building my
personal brand on the side making
affiliate marketing income in a little
bit of YouTube ads and here and there
doing a few other projects personally so
what I would recommend is a couple
things clarify scale and automate number
one clarify I think I want I want you to
focus first and foremost on the business
business is business you gotta get your
money dialed in your clients consistent
results for your clients consistent so
when I say clarify I want you to clarify
how much a month you need to live on I
want you to clarify how much a month you
need to operate and I want you to be
realistic about that because one of the
things learning as a freelancer you know
man you got software expenses you got
hosting expenses or you got to get some
hard drives to back some stuff up you've
got money that doesn't come in as quick
as you thought it was you've got gear
you may need there's even you don't want
to panic you but and I'd probably even
do the best at this but there's even
potentially insurance
is there's just different things where a
lot of times I think we underpriced
ourselves we need to hustle and I've
done some free work and some bootstrap
work but even if you don't charge it yet
I want you to clarify real operational
expenses of what it would take to run
this freelance company um clarify how
much you need to live on as I told you I
knew exactly what was coming in my wife
and I were living in Vegas I would had
the three clients and I was actually a
little comfortable on that because 60k a
year as a base in addition to all my
other income as just being side hustle
income was really really comfortable
it's a story for another day eventually
I lost all three clients in one month
and that's what propelled me into
full-time solo entrepreneurship and I
was building my personal brand thank God
so that I was able to actually go quite
quickly into recovering all that income
and being independent but step one
clarify we'll go into the other two
steps but what do you think so far is
that making sense do you know those
numbers yeah I do and it's not like it's
not a bunch man I'm I'm a single guy you
know rince not that high for me I have
family and different things like that a
lot of people that are just kind of
helped me helping me through the
Entrepreneurship and and are just ready
to support me I don't know my expenses
are not that high but I I could I could
do better being very specific you know I
have quite a bit of apps you know I'd
like the update I do also videography
cinematography and different things like
that so I'd like to get new equipment
for that so just budgeting having
exactly what I want and need you know
versus pulling on different resources
but what I have I have a budget for my
my my bare necessities I do I've
calculated that and actually with my
client net we just what I have along the
clients how I have just right now I can
maintain that but obviously I want
growth well I love that and also clarify
Christopher said legal expenses of
course like there's are you incorporated
you set up like an LLC no that's I'm
literally like in the next hour I'm
working with someone on that yeah I mean
you yeah you want to get smart about
taxes you want to make sure you're
maximizing tax deductions you want to
lino lay a foundation and this is brick
by brick and piece by piece but the
other thing I want you to clarify is
again your services right now you're in
a good experimental
but what can happen with client work is
man there's a vibe with the church you
knew um they love it they're paying you
it's cool but then some other client
like is a total headache because they
thought you meant this and you didn't so
like if you haven't clarifying your
freelance services putting them into
words putting in deliverables timelines
expectations and defining sustainability
for you that's just kind of step one so
let me ask that's the first thing then
the second because and I'm not even
thinking of really about your personal
brand is scale like once you kind of you
you know what you're doing for this
actor you know what you're doing for
this psychologist you you it's great
that you're you're covering the bills
during a great spot the next step is
scale before and this is the thing we
probably hit on like every coffee with
Cannell but before I think you spread
yourself too thin
into even really worrying about the
music side of things for you or your
YouTube channel I honestly think that
it's wise to put that on the back burner
a little bit meaning back burner
stovetop the front thing is it's cranked
up on high as your freelance business
your digital marketing agency back
burner is like it's on simmer you get a
little inspiration you drop something
there but business is business and you
want to clarify your key business and
those first steps scale it your question
is how do I double revenue how do i
triple revenue and a bottleneck of that
is you're the bottleneck if you're the
deliverable for this whole thing how
many clients how many clients do you
think you could take on before you're
maxed out maybe four or five maybe like
two more you know that's another
question I know that's huge thank you
for taking so much your time yeah charge
for this like I don't even know where to
start with that you know one of the
things that kind of a little spooky like
I'm gonna spend all this time with you
and giving you my creativity because
that's part of my my responsibility is
to create create create for you build
your brand and then strategize and then
actually go into production but I'm
spending all this time how do I even
charge for you know creating and
strategy step one clarify literally the
hard costs of the deliverables even what
you think your time is worth and want it
to be worth
even you only have so many hours in a
day but then step two it's also it's
what the market will pay so I've done
and for $250 a week I've done like
full-on man in G people's Facebook page
chopping up micro concept for them and
posting multiple times a day
I was probably underpaid for the fat but
I have you'd it as an education and I
would scale one project into the next
project and raise my prices as I went
so it's also market demand here's what
you're gonna face if you're gonna scale
and you max out at five clients you
either a have to bring on more team or a
VA or some other infrastructure or just
go boutique and raise your prices and
hope that your clients can bear that
price raised because those are the only
opportunities for you to scale unless
there's some other income streams so big
advice I'm giving you is also definitely
kind of seasonal its stages it's not all
at once and it's not easy not because
the scale process can have chute you
know that that client says no or
whatever but that's why you clarify
first scale second and the reason I say
scale is I think for a lot of us
sometimes people say follow your passion
and I think that that could be bad
advice I think that the power of
entrepreneurship is that we can fund our
passion by by getting our clarifying our
business scaling that revenue and it's
not that you would I mean whatever
you're hustling all as an entrepreneur
you might be hustling eight ten twelve
hour days five days a week whatever on
your grind but then you know you want to
do your music thing and stuff too I
think that at first is knowing that
that's like a passion but eventually if
you got a little bit of automation in
your business maybe like an assistant or
somebody that goes and shoots for you or
does something for you
now you can fund your passion I mean I'm
living that right now I could fund
whatever project I want to work on kind
of a thing for people's mindset that's
kind of related to probably like some
music and some motivation some time dude
I gonna strop I'm gonna do it I just you
know what I mean because but I built the
business first
so I'm saying build the business that's
what I would do I'd focus on that I
would then think about scaling and
doubling revenue or just increasing
revenue and then the last step is I
would think about automation which is
kind of part of that scale piece meaning
how can you make it reoccurring where
you're no longer trading your time for
money the biggest thing we run into is
entrepreneurs we need to create leverage
here's the book recommendation the
e-myth have you ever heard of this one
um so it's called the e-myth
and Elina will drop it in the comments
but the e-myth revisited and what did
the premise of it is that a lot of us I
fell into this exact trap I was a video
editor as a videographer I was building
websites I was helping people with
social media and it emits entually says
you know it's why most small businesses
don't work and what to do about it
because what happens is we're actually
not business owners you and me were
actually not entrepreneurs usually at
first we are technicians which means if
you make great cupcakes the best
cupcakes in the world you can only make
so many cupcakes so running a cupcake
business and making cupcakes is two
different things
technically a business is something that
you work on but it works without you now
it might take years to get it to that
point that's the mindset that you want
to start adopting to realize that like
to have multiple businesses is
eventually Umbro this is a process I'm
not saying this is in seven days like or
even two years necessarily but like
thinking that you you eventually have a
truly digital marketing company that is
one of your businesses you're also a
recording artist and you start your own
label or whatever for yourself whatever
you get the idea but the digital
marketing company can fund that project
and other projects problem is most of us
is creatives and as technicians we do it
all at once we spread ourselves too thin
there's no there's not like serious bank
to fund it and so that's what automation
is how do I oughta mate this to realize
right now to serve these eventually five
clients takes me 50 hours a week and if
I I and I can't go on vacation this is
what a lot of people find themselves if
I took 50 hours off I'd be behind 50
the hours so you want to be thinking
it's one of the best mind sets to start
working on right now even if it takes
you a while to get there check out the
e-myth revisited read that but you want
to be thinking okay how do I get out of
my business so I'm not working in my
business I'm working on my business and
I'm able to like pull the levers install
the things automate the processes and I
said all that an answer to your other
question of what I do with my personal
brand I personally don't think that your
personal brand you said you know other
people need to see that it's work for me
in order to hire me I don't think that's
true I think that if you got you got
results for the church get a video
testimonial from the church like get
them to do a written or video
testimonial for you because if they're
loving what you're doing then the people
are gonna hire you because you get them
results they're gonna hire you because
you managed their Facebook page they're
gonna hire you because you can shoot the
video for them and eventually your
assistant or person helping you can help
shoot the video for them but you deliver
on results and I I think that you could
chip away at your personal brand you
could chip away it I having a solid
Instagram account so you could DM people
and have clarity in your bio so you can
attract clients and land more clients
but it sounds to me like you really
don't need a lot of clients I'd finally
say I would try to get to five stay at
five and try to automate five and think
about automating processes by the way
automation can be using bench accounting
so that like the accounting side of your
business is happening more by like
online automation could be like having
eventually a VA that's maybe a working
overseas so it's different than having
to pay somebody $60,000 a year in LA
that she can't afford right now or more
right and so clarify scale and then
automate focus on the business get your
money right get your money doubled yeah
and that's not even your money as a
business owner that's kind of the way
it's the business's money the way the
business runs so you need way more than
you think you do and people are afraid
to talk about money I know you aren't
but but people like oh you're just
trying to get money like you as a
business owner it you need money for
taxes
like you d like you need to make you
know for every hundred dollars you just
need to say peace to 40% so like even
when you get you get especially in LA
bro like even when you get some money
you don't eat it's not even all your
money the government's gonna want to
take some and that's why you want smart
tax strategies bro this is a journey I
kind of threw a lot at you right now but
I think this was a good spark
conversation any final thoughts or
questions about this no man I just want
to say do you are inspiring the world
and I'm one of those that you're
inspiring and thank you so much for
letting me on and answer my questions I
felt your heart in it you meant every
single word and god bless you man and
everything that you do brother yeah I
appreciate you what's your name I mean
Prince purposed but what's your name oh
my name is Prince okay perfect okay cool
I mean yeah man it's Prince purpose on
all social media and everything is
Prince purpose calm everything man hey I
appreciate you so much dude I love what
you're doing you're already got you got
great momentum like you said you're
already hitting it you're in a super-rad
situation I think the next three five
and 10 years of your life are gonna be
insane just keep grinding and I think
you could build something significant
and I could tell you're Purpose Driven
ambitious you want to make a difference
and really help people and so I think
you could build some incredible stuff
man
wow man thanks so much brother god bless
you god bless ya man we had prints on
hey one of the things that that kind of
brought top of mind for me we talked
about clarify come on scale automate why
are you trying to scale something that
you don't even know what it is
you got to clarify first then you want
to scale that thing and then automate
and preferably one thing well I'm trying
to work on 17 businesses what do you
have one business that's running well
yet cuz if you don't got one business
running well yet and so I'm not talking
to Prince with this tip right now I'm
talking to you how are you trying to
build why you trying to chase two
rabbits can't catch either most of us is
creatives and entrepreneurs we're trying
to chase 14 rabbits
get one rabbit Ketchum we said this on a
past episode don't chase two rabbits
chase one catch it tame it train it
dress it bow tie Butler teach it skills
get it automated get it so that that
rabbit showing up to work so you can
sleep in take a day off and then because
that rabbit is produced it for you go
chase another rabbit if you try and
chase two rabbits you end up catching
neither and I want to recommend our
thick media tool guide we talked about
like bench accounting for example like
there's so many different things when it
comes to building an online business we
just dropped because we get these
questions all the time like what
software do you use what accounting
stuff do you use wow that is the largest
nail okay we've got you know how to edit
with the music we use so specifically
live-streaming tools right now I'm
streaming on stream yard for example and
it's really easy way to stream
so that's think media tools calm if
you're interested in any of those
questions Christopher what legal
services do you use just to sign up and
get incorporated we've used things like
Rocket Lawyer in like LegalZoom at the
scale of business we're at now we're
working with like a firm and we have a
CPA and an attorney and a financial
advisor and it's a whole suite of a team
and so but you definitely don't need
that there's its stages and this is why
it's really important to recognize what
stage you're in because for example I
wouldn't you don't need that you
probably don't need a dedicated firm at
the level you just you do something like
a simple online tool like Legal Zoom to
get going get set up you know or just
some local person I will say this a lot
of CPAs and tax people do not understand
online entrepreneurship the nature of
online business in multiple streams of
revenue new school kind of YouTube
income and whatnot so be very careful
you want to make sure you do your due
diligence and work with somebody who
really knows what's happening but hey if
you big in value hit the like button if
you want to join us each week the coming
up we're
to be on either Wednesday morning we're
gonna do a few on Monday evening PT
Pacific time la time Las Vegas time
where I'm streaming to you from and we
will be I'm pumped for more coffee with
candles but we got Joshua up next my man
Joshua how's it going bro where are you
streaming from how's this thing been
affecting you this Cova 19 thing and how
can I help ya man thanks for chatting
with me thanks for taking the time can
you hear me alright
yeah I can hear ya excellent excellent
so yeah I'm in Waterloo Ontario Canada
it's about 60 miles west of Toronto and
it's well well my particular areas and
hit that hard you can see I got a
breathing device here so I'm being
actually extra careful right if I get
this coded think I am probably out for
the count quite honestly so I'm being
really really strict about who I'm
butting in my house and that even uh
goes to like caregivers early every
rotation of about like either nine
caregivers what I've dropped that down
to three and it's kind of made life kind
of interesting and difficult to them
more working on other people's schedule
then more my schedule right now and what
what this coded pandemic has down the
idiom it's gonna wrench into my plans
events about a year ago I started a
youtube cooking show and kind of with
the twist called the kitchen right so
like a handicapped dying in the kitchen
now I can't physically do any of the
cooking and whatnot myself but you know
with with my directions and with my
whatnot I tell the person who's like
generally like a kitchen new but what to
do I'm a and then just goes to show that
like really anybody can cook some good
stuff right
so my give me and somebody else who
doesn't know what they're doing and I
physically can't do it myself that's the
idea right like we can make some really
good stuff and it was uh I got no two
episodes that it was it was pretty good
the production quality was at best but
you know after two episodes we
more than 600 views we had you know 70
subscribers stuff like that so I'm
pretty excited where things were going
but it was huh it was just too much work
for me by myself so like I would learn
how to use the cameras and again because
I can't really do it myself would be
telling somebody how to do the camera
and stuff like that and it was remaining
quite a bit of work for just myself so I
pulled back from it and then over the
months I put together a team of
videographers video editors people that
are good with sound stuff like that
and I was really excited and honestly we
were about to shoot our very first
episode like a relaunch and kovat
strikes and we can't get together
anymore um so I don't even know if my
team's gonna come back right because
they gonna worry about putting food on
the table they gotta worry about you
know making a real income they can't
really put their time towards something
that may or may not pay off for a while
so I don't know if they're coming back
is this where I pivot I mean food is my
passion it's what I want to do but do I
join
evidence something else do I do it in a
different manner so that I I don't know
I'm doing something a little bit
different like instead of videotaping
the recipes and editing maybe you know
wow I actually have somebody here I make
something cool I take some pictures and
then just kind of do like I'm livestream
post some pictures talk about it sit
here with one of my workers and like try
the food and talk about the food do I do
that or do I hit it off totally because
I've also thought about doing something
else but I'm not sure I'm not I'm not
sure it's another it's a sort of passion
of mine but what do you think man yeah
what what's the channel a lot of people
are asking what's the channel so far
okay I put it in the in the in our
private chat here in the in the stream
yards it's it's called handy in the
kitchen
awesome so yeah but I haven't check it
out so let me see here and I don't worry
I've learned so much I've learned so
much so I'm doing in these videos you
can like in the first one you you don't
hear my breathing machine out loud you
hear it a little bit but then my voice
is super weak right and then in the
second video I didn't take out the
ventilator sound my voice was strong but
then the ventilator was super strong and
now aren't even here you're getting me
talking right now and there's no there's
no there's no ventilator sound in the
background I hope so you know I figured
that out like I figured out a lot of
stuff I'm really excited to get going
they just nazi for me to get in a room
with four or five people right now where
I don't know where they've been like I
said I get covin I'm ghost yeah well man
I mean first of all Joshua is so
grateful that you're on the show and
just super inspired by let your ambition
and what you've pulled off and what
you've put together you know building a
team and and and getting a couple videos
out I think that you're being of course
absolutely wise kovat happens you can't
you got to be really careful who you're
around and so it's the disruption that
is absolutely real
my initial question in response to
pivoting is you know you said you said
you could livestream or you could do a
couple other things what truly are your
resources in terms of what you are able
to do by yourself
by myself is not a lot like once I'm at
my computer I'm okay but anything that
requires any sort of work with your
hands like I got adaptive equipment and
stuff like that all her my computer but
if I'm using uh like you've been trying
to take pictures or video if that's
outside the can be there I cannot do it
myself so I do need some assistance with
that so you've been setting up like a
tripod with a camera on it and getting
it focus where I can be got it my mind
numbingly frustrating with somebody
who's you know who their their job is to
help me like you know do my personal
care and help me eat stuff like that
they're not they weren't
ever how to use it you know a DSLR or a
handycam or a GoPro or anything like
that so and you were and you were
watching videos getting your education
figuring it all out and then having tell
someone there's also a bit of a barrier
that and I'm not sure and appreciative
of maybe you don't understand it but
like wait when I'm not actually
physically hands-on with the camera the
person has it in their hands it could be
a bit of a frustrating back and forth
almost like if they're trying to figure
it out but I'm like saying like hey show
me this and show me that then I'll
figure it out it's like it can be yeah I
can be frustrating and time-consuming
yeah I can't even imagine but I mean
massive respect for your tenacity your
patience your innovation your
adaptability I mean it makes complete
sense i i i I find it frustrating when I
can go demonstrate to when I'm training
somebody and so you know you're the
level of overcoming limitations is truly
inspiring and I'm seeing a lot of that
in the comments too and so really
grateful for you here's the thing what
you can do is you really can crush it at
your computer I mean it sounds like so
you are able to livestream you're able
to watch create are you editing the
videos then I did the other thing I'm
pretty slow about it um what what I
would like to do is have most people or
somebody else do most of the front-end
editing and then I do the finishing
because those do videos they're about
six seven minutes each there's about see
40 minutes of footage from three or four
cameras and it probably honestly took me
about 45 to 55 hours just just because
I'm a bit stuff like that so I'd like to
get the burden off of me for the mass
portion of it and then I can do the
finishing touches to get it the way I
want right yeah got it so you know a
couple things when I think about and
thanks so much for coming on the show in
terms of pivoting I mean we've kind of
defined that like bringing people in
physically is out of the question
I think that something that is
interesting to me is I mean the level
bro of you just being innovative you
know not making excuses and figuring
this stuff out you built that initial
team you got the major discouraging blow
of kovat and then not being able to get
together with them what my thought is
just looking at what you are able to do
and even with what you're able to do
where you're at I love the fact that you
even put you mean you're put in a grind
net people that are not in the same
circumstance aren't willing to work as
hard as you've worked and so the my
respect is off the charts my question is
a couple thoughts could you still create
some stuff potentially live streaming
you know and I think about like how
PewDiePie creates content he really just
records to a camera and then an editor
really makes it fancy he's basically
talking head and then an editor makes it
fancy and so I wonder the biggest asset
I see going for you is the fact that you
said I can get in front of a computer
you've got the six set up I mean your
office is dope by the way a lot of
people are complimenting it for you
that's my other passion and I thought
about doing something sports we're
waiting for a male sports it's kind of
yeah it's brutal actually now sports a
shutdown they may be shutdown all year
and so yeah I mean I would I would a I'd
be thinking about okay what can I do
from the computer what can I record or
livestream just like we're doing right
now how can I then maybe drop that to
the team you've already built on Dropbox
either to let them do heavy lifting on
the editing or most of the editing and
essentially DJ and lead you know a team
alternatively I'm not sure what your
resources are like but there are things
like vid tops if you create a simple
outline of a show which you maybe have
to put in the 30 hours the 60 hours 200
hours I mean in the terms of like maybe
giving the model of the first episode
the way you want it edited writing
things out on like Google Docs in term
of whatever but then essentially
delegating a service like that which
essentially just manages like overseas
editors can be I think 300 bucks a month
for four videos and maybe that's out of
the question but it might even be more
economical than whatever another team
but that's where I think it comes back
to I think that the chance to just go
live turn it on turn it off with no
editing and what I would encourage you
is again you know you're inspiring a ton
of people in our community but I think a
lot of people around the world need to
just hear your hope your optimism your
grit your determination obviously a lot
of people in the handicapped community I
think you could definitely build a
community and encourage others so I just
like you're seeing what your limitations
are or truly what more than limitations
like what I was just shut down now
because of kovat I think it's what you
still can do and bro the level of
pivoting does that make sense so I mean
I think it's live streaming I think it's
potentially deadly delegating editing
you already have a team in place Dropbox
you know or or letting when you go live
will do some of this sometimes if I do a
live stream and it's 1080p on YouTube I
can even do it unlisted and so I could
just like record to like the backend of
think media or think marketing unlisted
I could record for 60 minutes and all my
mess ups and all my stuff an editor can
just download that off YouTube drop it
in a timeline and puts up so even
without Dropbox or recording even to
your hard drive and uploading and
whatever else
remembering that it's about the content
value production value matters but it's
about the content value even more than
the production value and so the level of
like DSLR and depth of field and stuff
you've pulled off is is sick and let's
just believe that that'll come back you
know once this thing vaccine or whatever
it is dies down but in the meantime I
think that creating from right where you
are in whatever can be in front of the
computer and then inspiring picking a
niche that is as intelligent as possible
for
now as you said you know sports might
not be the best the cooking you know
commentary wise from there you are maybe
that's maybe you could keep doing that
on handy in the kitchen or maybe that
projects just in on pause for a second
and maybe there's something else you do
so you can keep hustling during this
time any thoughts on that yeah that
makes sense to me
yeah the live streaming and yeah just
kind of using like I said about a week
ago when I asked about using things like
fiber and I wrote down that that vid
tops is that a what's the URL it's like
hey Charles calm or something like yeah
yeah vid chops dot-com and and they're
pricing plans like 600 a month or two
ninety-five a month for four videos so
if it's like a video a week that's 300
bucks and it's a video a week which is
significantly kind of more affordable
than like a domestic editor and you
shoot the raw video drop it in Dropbox
they edit it they could get back to you
you can tell them whatever revisions you
want and and you know think media we
have like a little partnership with them
so it's actually even a little bit more
affordable like 265 and it's 535 for the
whole deal like for the unlimited edits
so couple videos a week or if it's you
know um and yeah so that's something to
check out also though I'm gonna pull it
up again a couple people they've been
asking oh yeah so people are asking how
they can follow you is this the best way
to follow you handy in the kitchen I'm
also on Twitter who are you on Twitter I
don't even know it recently
yeah I'm Josh underscore one underscore
day and it's like the number one kind of
Josh one day is like why
like online moniker type thing awesome
man well hey has it's been valuable
today yeah it's been good it's really
encouraging because I I didn't know if
you know I should just sit on it for a
while or if I should you know do what
kind of do what you said what you see
John said I was thinking about it yeah I
love it man bro I'm super inspired I'm
grateful we were able to connect and the
level of just not excuse making that
you're making it's it's a beautiful man
it's really amazing and um and yeah I
think I love the fact that you're
thinking about just taking action even
if very frustratingly a couple projects
are on pause you know maybe it's maybe
this side thing of going live a couple
times a week or whatever whatever you
need maybe it just kind of bridges the
gap maybe it turns into the main thing
the key is that I love is that you're
just not gonna stand still but you're
gonna move in and just edit stream what
boring life it's wrong if you don't have
anything to do right so my mana just
what I got so right so love it bro
that's amazing so Josh underscore one
underscore day on Twitter thank you so
much for jumping on the show and excited
because I really want to believe that
you know again even with the skills and
stuff you learned there in this time
maybe or delegating and vid chops or
whatever that let's hope this co vyd
thing and sooner than later and you know
that we can get back to those projects
as well and get that team back cooking
in the kitchen
yeah because my man appreciate you
thanks again for coming on John yeah
I'll keep in touch - alright take care
peace
do my man Joshua Court leave if I said
that right and super great coffee with
Cannell session today hey right now it's
time to go all in with YouTube it's time
to go all in with e-commerce look no
matter what man just press record your
first videos are gonna be your worst
videos start messy press record today
don't overthink it
what if you post a hundred videos 250
videos and it doesn't turn into anything
well sometimes you learn sometimes you
win sometimes you learn I did a project
back in the day most people don't even
know about it it's called think
international 279 uploads by the way
back in 2010 founded by Jeff Moore's and
Sean kennel we were interviewing church
leaders we were sharing about church
marketing and and a lot of different
stuff covered some different conferences
did a lot of things you know we grew to
15,000 subscribers but in that niche
there wasn't you know like a ton of
affiliate marketing or anything like
that it was actually a non-profit we
started back in 2010 um and here's the
deal did we ever make money no did it
retire us
no we like broke even we were able to
like travel and do some things and and
get a computer and do some things we
were hustling 272 videos did it blow up
no did it you know did we get famous
nope
but sometimes you win sometimes you
learn and I have a couple successful
YouTube channels now but people don't
know about the four quote-unquote failed
once now I don't think that was a
failure it helped people served people
we learned a lot and I've learned that
failures are actually stepping stones to
success and I'll tell you that the
reason we're helping people with our
products or programs our channels and we
we have advice that works when it comes
to YouTube is because we've made some
many mistakes when it comes to YouTube
if you like me have uploaded over 2000
videos on YouTube which I have for
myself and for my clients 1,600 of which
were not very good and did not do very
well you'd be freaking smart to you know
Thomas Edison is famous for saying I
didn't fail 10,000 times I just found
10,000 ways that didn't work until I
found the one way which was the light
bulb that actually worked you got to
keep experimenting got to keep testing
you got to keep posting and I'm so
inspired by Joshua because even the
stuff he wants to work on right now he
can't work on right now but he's still
gonna go live he's still gonna press
record he's still gonna punch her in the
face punch perfectionism in the face and
press record my friends creators create
leaders lead and now is the time to be
pushing out content publishing content
Shawn are you saying that if I start
YouTube right now I'm gonna be a
millionaire in the next three months
because of everything that's happening
I'm assuredly not saying that I'm saying
that if you start YouTube right now
you're gonna be positioning yourself for
breakthrough in six months or six years
I don't know but I do know that if you
don't take action nothing's gonna happen
that fortune favors the bold that you
gotta starve your fears feed your faith
and press record and that you got to
create a lot of bad videos to get to
your good videos you got to be willing
to suck at the start you got to be
willing to practice in public and get
your content out there because that's
what leads you to the insights that will
not only grow your YouTube channel its
what also leads you to self-awareness I
learned clarity I got personal clarity
from trying a lot of things and
discovering things I either didn't like
I wasn't good at I didn't really
understand I didn't want to stick with
and what we're so afraid of is what if I
started YouTube channel and Sara from
high school judges me dude who cares
about Sara man I don't care about Sara
you don't care about Sara well you are
caring about Sara you need to stop
caring about what Sara thinks and you
need to start your YouTube channel I'm
so worried that if I start a YouTube
channel I might be embarrassed because
I'm gonna get all these D likes dislikes
and all these negative comments no you
not no one's gonna see it if you got a
hundred dislikes you'd be blessed cuz
you're not I'm gonna get a hundred views
on your first upload and I know there's
a lot of fears what are people gonna
think judgement fear of failure you
can't feel fear failure because failure
is an essential ingredient to success
you got to fall in love with failure you
got to fall in love you know I had that
freelance business back in 2009 I gave
some advice earlier to my Man Prince and
I had a pretty successful freelance
business in 2015 and then it scaled into
full-time entrepreneurship or
solopreneur personal brand that I'm
doing now but in 2009 we did alright we
grew we made money we paid bills we paid
taxes we got more gear but did I got my
freak I got punched in the face man I
didn't know how to charge I had horrible
clients I was tired I was overwhelmed I
hated what I was doing at times but
clear vision media which is one of my
other failed channels and all it really
was was a portfolio for my work was a
learning experience I would say that
this was a failure but I didn't believe
in failure failures are stepping stones
to success and so all that was on here
you want to see some of my work someday
it's called clear vision Shaun canto
productions clear vision media so five
years ago seven years ago eight years
ago I just started posting videos and
this is when I was doing a ton of
freelance work man I got Christian
hip-hop not Christian
I got hip-hop videos from Seattle
rappers on this channel right I'm making
music videos uh I'm doing all kinds of
stuff back then and I was learning I was
I was reading books I was studying I was
taking courses I was going to
conferences I was having some success
along the way but having probably more
failure than success but I was posting
videos on my grind finding ways to
monetize putting out content because
this is a Mexican restaurant called
Playa Bonita in Marysville Washington
you want a little bit check this out
this is in fact let me give you the good
audio let's just get the good audio on
this one and you got to see it
we go you got to see this this ad I did
for a Mexican restaurant an hour north
of SIA Bonita a Mexican restaurant is
all about traditional and authentic
Mexican food delicious and plentiful the
festive and family-friendly atmosphere
will make you feel like you're dining in
Old Mexico family owned and operated
you'll be treated like family every time
enjoy signature drinks and Mexican beer
as well as lunch special served 11:00 to
3:00 seven days a week
aya Bonita Mexican restaurant stop by
one of the three locations today and
have your own little piece of Mexico
you got a hustle man you got a grind man
and I've been hustling and so I want to
encourage you creators create right now
it's time to go all-in on YouTube and
you got to post videos and you got to
stop overthinking about it and you got
to stop worrying about your next upload
in the terms of like uploading it over
editing it posting it and then staring
at it post and pray and just watching it
and then taking three weeks off and fear
if you got to do that do that get back
on the horse and start again
but like it's dude I'm not even worried
about the next video I'm worried about
the next 100 in the next 1000 it's
always the next one every single one's
an experiment of course I care about the
results but I'm just committed to the
grind committed to the process I don't
do 10 push-ups today and expect that I'm
gonna be Brad Pitt Fight Club ripped in
a week I gotta be thinking about
committing to doing push-ups every
single day and I've been slacking so
I've not gonna been actually growing in
this area but my goal that I tell myself
even though I've not been very faithful
with it is to someday be Brad Pitt Fight
Club ripped how do you get those results
well you actually have to keep doing
push-ups apparently for him it's
cigarettes and Budweiser as well as we
can see in his hand there as he's
holding that beer but as how do you get
there is
you got to keep doing push-ups it's not
about the next pushup
it's about doing push-ups every single
day and I've been slacking but I haven't
been slacking on my video push-ups I've
been doing them for the last ten years
hitting upload hitting punching fear in
the face pressing record and uploading
the video so this is a practice friend
fall in love with failure daily
discipline keep uploading videos keep
researching keep learning keep posting
keep going come on Dori that right just
keep swimming there's at the right
reference
come on finding Nemo just creeps women
you got to just keep going and most
people overestimate what they can
accomplish in one year but they
underestimate what they can accomplish
in five to ten years we're here to help
you pivot your plan at think media and
really adapt during this time I believe
you can have massive success right now
and there's a lot of opportunities in
the world and things are being disrupted
there's a lot of problems in the world
and entrepreneurs solve problems and I
believe you're a purpose-driven
entrepreneur if you're watching this but
it's really goes beyond it's not like
I'm gonna do push-ups for the next week
no I'm gonna do push-ups for the rest of
my life because I don't want to I want
to stay healthy and I want to get come
on Brad Pitt fight cup whipped the
push-up analogy is not something Sean's
been doing because there's no guns
but the push-up analogy related to
YouTube and creating content and
building your businesses you got to keep
showing up man keep doing YouTube and
e-commerce is blowing up right now we're
gonna do more on that in the future Don
I appreciate you being here Christopher
Alena Rachel
Wendy super grateful are we back we are
back next Wednesday same time same place
just kidding it's next Tuesday so save
the date
that's the fifth and excited to see you
thanks for being here on coffee with Ken
oh if you got value today hit the like
button tag somebody share this with
somebody to watch the replay we had
three really great conversations talking
about a lot of strategies today and
thanks again for being here excited to
have more people on the show in the
future coffee with Cannell zero zero
five in the history books and in the
meantime keep crushing it keep smashing
it appreciates you now go punch fear in
the face punch perfectionism in the face
and press record see ya
appreciate you later